[Music]
uh
come on
foreign
[Music]
thank you
me
hello
the select committee to investigate the
january 6th attack on the united states
capitol will be in order
without objection the chair is
authorized to declare the committee in
recess at any point
pursuant to house deposition authority
regulation 10
the chair announces the committee's
approval to release the deposition
material presented during today's
hearing
good afternoon
at our last hearing
we told the story of a scheme driven by
donald trump
to pressure former vice president mike
pence to illegally overturn the election
results
we showed that when the pressure
campaign failed and mike pence fulfilled
his constitutional obligation
donald trump turned a violent mob loose
on him
we showed that the mob came within
roughly 40 feet
of the vice president
today
we'll show that what happened to mike
pence wasn't an isolated part of donald
trump's scheme to overturn the election
in fact
pressuring public servants into
betraying their oaths was a fundamental
part of the playbook
and a handful of election officials in
several key states stood between donald
trump and the upending of american
democracy
as we began today
it's important to remember
when we count the votes for president we
count the votes state by state
for the most part
the candidates who win the popular vote
in a state
wins all the state's electoral college
votes
and whoever wins a majority of the
electoral college votes
wins the presidency
so when donald trump tried to overturn
the election results he focused on just
a few states
he wanted officials at the local and
state level to say the vote was tainted
by widespread
fraud and throughout the results
even though as we showed last week there
wasn't any voter fraud that could have
overturned the election results
and like mike pence
these public servants wouldn't go along
with donald trump's scheme
and when they wouldn't embrace the big
lie and substitute the will of the
voters with donald trump's will to
remain in power
donald trump worked to ensure they'd
face the consequences
threats to people's livelihood and lives
threats of violence that donald trump
trump knew about and amplified
and in
our other hearings
we can't just look backward at what
happened in late 2020 and in the early
2021
because the danger hadn't gone away
our democracy endured a mighty test on
january 6th and in the days before
we say our institutions hell
but what does that really mean
democratic institutions aren't
abstractions or ideas
they are local officials who oversee
elections
secretaries of state
people in whom we've placed our trust
that they'll carry out their duties
but what if they don't
two weeks ago
new mexico held its primary elections
one county commission refused to certify
the results
citing vague unsupported claims dealing
with dominion voting machines
the court stepped in
saying new mexico law required the
commission to certify the results
two of the three members of the
commission finally relented
one still refused
saying his vote quote isn't based on any
evidence it's not based on any facts
it's only based on my gut feeling
and my own intuition
and that's all i need
by the way
a few months ago
this county commissioner was found
guilty of illegally entering the capitol
grounds on january 6.
this story reminds us of a few things
first
as we've shown in our previous hearings
claims that widespread voter fraud
tainted the 2020 presidential election
have always been alive
donald trump knew they were alive and he
kept amplifying them anyway
everything we described today the
relentless destructive pressure campaign
on state and local officials was all
based on a lie
donald trump knew it
he did it anyway
second the lie hasn't gone away
it's corrupting our democratic
institutions
people who believe that lie are now
seeking positions of public trust
and as seen in new mexico
that oath to be
to the people
they serve will take a back seat to
their commitment to the big lie if that
happens
who will make sure our institutions
don't break under the pressure
we won't have close calls we'll have a
catastrophe
my distinguished colleague from
california mr schiff will present much
of the select committee's finding on
this matter
first i'm pleased to recognize our vice
chair ms cheney of wyoming for any
opening statement she care to offer
thank you very much mr chairman
today we will begin examining president
trump's effort to overturn the election
by exerting pressure on state officials
and state legislatures
donald trump had a direct and personal
role in this effort as did rudy giuliani
as did john eastman
in other words the same people who were
attempting to pressure vice president
mike pence to reject electoral votes
illegally we're also simultaneously
working to reverse the outcome of the
2020 election at the state level
each of these efforts to overturn the
election is independently serious each
deserves attention both by congress
and by our department of justice
but as the federal court has already
indicated these efforts were also part
of a broader plan
and all of this was done in preparation
for january sixth
i would note two points for particular
focus today first
today you will hear about calls made by
president trump to officials of georgia
and other states
as you listen to these tapes
keep in mind what donald trump already
knew at the time he was making those
calls
he had been told over and over again
that his stolen election allegations
were nonsense
for example this is what former attorney
general bill barr said to president
trump about allegations in georgia
we
took a look hard look at this ourselves
and based on our
uh review of it including the interviews
of the key witnesses
uh the fulton county uh
allegations were had no merit
the ballots under the table
uh were legitimate ballots they weren't
in a suitcase they had been pre-opened
for eventually feeding into the machine
all the stuff about the water leak and
that there was some subterfuge involved
we felt there was some confusion but but
there was no evidence of a subterfuge to
create an opportunity to feed things
into the count
and uh
so we didn't see any evidence of of
fraud in the in the fulton county
episode
and acting deputy attorney general
richard donahue told donald trump this
and i said something to the effect of
sir we've done dozens of investigations
hundreds of interviews
the major allegations are not supported
by the evidence developed
mr trump was told by his own advisors
that he had no basis for his stolen
election claims
yet he continued to pressure state
officials to change the election results
second you will hear about a number of
threats
and efforts to pressure state officials
to reverse the election outcome
one of our witnesses today gabriel
sterling explicitly warned president
trump about potential violence on
december 1st 2020 more than a month
before january 6th
you will see excerpts from that video
repeatedly today
it has all
gone
too
far
all of it
joe jennifer today asked for kris krebs
a patriot who ran sissa to be shot
a 20-something tech in gwinnett county
today
has death threats and a noose put out
saying he should be hung for treason
because he was transferring a report on
batches from an ems to a county computer
so we could read it
it has to stop
mr president
you have not condemned these actions or
this language
senators you have not condemned this
language or these actions
this has to stop
we need you to step up and if you're
going to take a position of leadership
show some
my boss secretary raffensburg
his address is out there they have
people doing caravans running their
house they've had people come onto their
property
it has to stop
this is elections
this is the backbone of democracy and
all of you who have not said a damn word
are complicit in this
the point is this
donald trump did not care about the
threats of violence
he did not condemn them he made no
effort to stop them he went forward with
his fake allegations anyway
one more point
i would urge all of those watching today
to focus on the evidence the committee
will present
don't be distracted by politics this is
serious
we cannot let america become a nation of
conspiracy theories and thug violence
finally i want to thank our witnesses
today
for all of your service to our country
today all of america will hear about the
selfless actions of these men and women
who acted honorably to uphold the law
protect our freedom and preserve our
constitution
today mr chairman we will all see an
example of what truly makes america
great thank you mr chairman i yield back
without objection the chair recognizes
the gentleman from california mr schiff
for an opening statement
thank you mr chairman and madam vice
chair
on november 3rd 2020 donald trump ran
for re-election to the office of the
presidency
and he lost
his opponent joe biden finished ahead in
the key battleground states of arizona
michigan wisconsin pennsylvania georgia
and elsewhere
nevertheless and for the first time in
history
the losing presidential candidate fought
to hold on to power
as we have seen in previous hearings he
did so through a variety of means
on election day he sought to stop the
counting of the vote knowing that the
millions of absentee ballots elections
officials would be counting on election
day
and thereafter would run strongly
against him and deliver a victory to joe
biden
next and when he could not stop the
counting
he tried to stop state legislatures and
governors from certifying the results of
the election
he went to court and filed dozens of
frivolous lawsuits making
unsubstantiated claims of fraud
when that too failed he mounted a
pressure campaign directed at individual
state legislators
to try to get them to go back into
session and either declare him the
winner
decertify joe biden as the winner
or send two slates of electors to
congress
one for biden
and one for him
and pressure vice president pence to
choose him
as the winner
but the state legislatures wouldn't go
along with this scheme
and neither would the vice president
none of the legislatures agreed to go
back into special session and declare
him
the winner
no legitimate state authority in the
states donald trump lost would agree to
appoint fake trump electors and send
them to congress
but this didn't stop the trump campaign
either
they assembled groups of individuals in
key battleground states and got them to
call themselves electors
created phony certificates associated
with these fake electors and then
transmitted these certificates to
washington and to the congress to be
counted during the joint session of
congress on january 6th
none of this worked
but according to federal district judge
david carter
former president trump and others likely
violated multiple federal laws by
engaging in this scheme
including conspiracy to defraud the
united states
you will hear evidence of the former
president and his top advisors direct
involvement in key elements of this plot
or what judge carter called a coup
in search of a legal theory
for as the judge explained
president trump's pressure campaign to
stop the electoral count
did not end with vice president pence it
targeted every tier of federal and state
elected officials
convincing state legislatures he said to
certify competing electors was essential
to stop the count
and ensure president trump's re-election
as we have seen in our prior hearings
running through this scheme was a big
lie that the election was plagued with
massive fraud and somehow stolen
you'll remember what pres the
president's own attorney general bill
barr
said he told the president about these
claims of massive fraud affecting the
outcome of the election
and uh
i told him that the stuff that his
people were shuttling out to the public
were both was [ __ ] i mean that the
claims of fraud were [ __ ]
the president's lie was
and is a dangerous cancer on the body
politic
if you can convince americans that they
cannot trust their own elections that
any time they lose it is somehow
illegitimate
then what is left but violence to
determine who should govern
this brings us to the focus of today's
hearing when state elections officials
refused to stop the count
donald trump and his campaign tried to
put pressure on them
when state executive officials refused
to certify him the winner of states he
lost
he applied more pressure when state
legislators refused to go back into
session and appoint trump electors he
amped up the pressure yet again
anyone who got in the way of donald
trump's continued hold on power after he
lost the election was the subject of a
dangerous and escalating campaign of
pressure
this pressure campaign brought angry
phone calls and texts armed protests
intimidation and all too often threats
of violence
and death
state legislators were singled out
so too were statewide elections
officials
even local elections workers
diligently doing their jobs were accused
of being criminals
and had their lives turned upside down
as we will show
the president's supporters heard the
former president's claims of fraud and
the false allegations he made against
state and local officials as a call to
action
stop the steal stop the steal
stop the steal
[Music]
you're a threat to democracy
you're the threat to
free and honest elections
and then about 45 minutes later we
started to hear the noises outside my
home and that's my stomach sunk and i
thought it's me and they're and then
it's just we don't know
what's gonna and the uncertainty of that
was what
was the fear like are they coming with
guns are they gonna attack my house
i'm in here with my kid you know it's
i'm trying to put in the bed
and so it was um
that was the scariest moment just not
knowing what was going to happen
this pressure campaign against state and
local officials spanned numerous
contested states
as you will see in this video produced
by the select committee
my name is josh roselmann i'm an
investigative council for the house
select committee to investigate the
january 6th attack on the united states
capital beginning in late november 2020
the president and his lawyers started
appearing before state legislators
urging them to give their electoral
votes to trump even though he lost the
popular vote i represent
president trump along with jenna ellis
and this is our fourth or fifth hearing
this election has to be turned around
because uh we won pennsylvania by a lot
and we won all of these swing states by
a lot this was a strategy with both
practical and legal elements the select
committee has obtained an email from
just two days after the election in
which a trump campaign lawyer named
cleta mitchell asked another trump
lawyer john eastman to write a memo
justifying the idea
when do you remember this coming up as
an option in the post-election period
for the first time
right after the election it might have
been before the election
eastman prepared a memo attempting to
justify this strategy which was
circulated to the trump white house rudy
giuliani's legal team and state
legislators around the country and he
appeared before the georgia state
legislature to advocate for it publicly
she could also do what the florida
legislature was prepared to do which is
to adopt a slate of electors yourself um
and when you add in the mix of the
significant statistical anomalies and
sworn evidence and video evidence of
outright election fraud i don't think
it's just your authority to do that but
quite frankly i think you have a duty to
do that to protect the
integrity of the election here in
georgia but republican officials in
several states released public
statements recognizing that president
trump's proposal was unlawful
for instance georgia governor brian kemp
called the proposal unconstitutional
while arizona house speaker rusty bowers
wrote that the idea would undermine the
rule of law
the pressure campaign to get state
legislators to go along with this team
intensified when president trump invited
delegations from michigan and
pennsylvania to the white house uh
either you or speaker chatfield did you
make the point to the president that you
were not going to do anything that
violated michigan law
i believe we did
uh whether or not was this exact word
i think the words that
i would more likely use we were going to
follow them
nevertheless the pressure continued the
next day president trump tweeted quote
hopefully the courts and or legislatures
will have the courage to do what has to
be done to maintain the integrity of our
elections and the united states of
america itself the world is watching
she posted multiple messages on facebook
listing the contact information for
officials and urging his supporters to
contact them to quote demand a vote on
certification
in one of those posts president trump
disclosed mike shirkey's personal phone
number to his millions of followers
all i remember is
receiving
over
just shy of 4 000 text messages over a
short period of time
calling to take action
it was a
loud noise
loud consistent cadence of
you know
we heard that
that the
trump uh folks are calling and asking
for
changes in the electors and you guys can
do this well you know they were
they were believing things that were
untrue
these efforts also involved targeted
outreach to state
legislators hi representatives
my name is angela mccallum i'm calling
from trump campaign headquarters in
washington dc you do have the power to
reclaim your authority and send a slate
of electors that will support president
trump and vice president pence from
president trump's lawyers and from trump
himself
and i've become friendly with
legislators that i didn't know four
weeks ago
another legislator pennsylvania house
speaker brian cutler received daily
voicemails from trump's lawyers in the
last week of november
mr speaker this is rudy giuliani and
jenna ellis we're calling you together
because we'd like to discuss obviously
the election
hello mr speaker uh this is jenna ellis
and i'm here with mayor uh giuliani
hey brian it's rudy
i really have something important to
call your attention that i think really
changes things cutler felt that the
outreach was inappropriate and asked his
lawyers to tell rudy giuliani to stop
calling but giuliani continued to reach
out
i understand that you don't want to talk
to me now
i just want to bring
some facts to your attention and talk to
you as a fellow republican on december
30th trump ally steve bannon announced a
protest at cutler's home we're getting
on the road and we're going down to
cutler we're going to start going to
offices and if we have to we're going to
go to homes and we're going to let them
know what we think about them there were
multiple protests i actually don't
remember the exact number there was at
least three i think um outside either my
district office or my home um and you're
correct my son my then 15 year old son
was home by himself for the first one
all of my personal information was
doxxed online
it was
my personal email my personal cell phone
my home phone number in fact we had to
disconnect our home phone
for about three days because it would
ring all hours of the night and would
fill up with messages
brian cutler we are outside
clerks facing felony charges in michigan
coal watchers denied access these ads
were another element in the effort the
trump campaign spent millions of dollars
running ads online and on television the
evidence is overwhelming
call your governor and legislators
demand they inspect the machines and
hear the evidence public pressure on
state officials often grew dangerous in
the lead-up to january 6th
[Applause]
what are we gonna do
what can you and i do state legislative
besides killing although we should not
do that i'm not advising that but i mean
what else you need to do
the right for treason
is death
the state pressure campaign and the
danger it posed to state officials and
the state capitals around the nation
was a dangerous precursor to the
violence we saw on january 6th at the
u.s capitol
today you will hear from rusty bowers
the republican speaker of the arizona
house of representatives
he will tell us about his conversations
with the president rudy giuliani and
john eastman
and what the president's team asked of
him and how his oath of office would not
permit it
you will then hear from brad
raffensberger the republican secretary
of state of georgia who trump directed
to quote fined eleven thousand seven
hundred eighty votes
that did not exist
but just the exact number of votes
needed to overtake joe biden
you will also hear from gabriel sterling
the chief operating officer his chief
operating officer about the spurious
claims of fraud in the elections in
georgia
and who responding to a cascading set of
threats to his elections team
warned the president to stop
that someone was going to get killed
and you will hear from juandrea andrea
sheamos a former local elections worker
in fulton county georgia
about how all of the lies about the
election impacted the lives
of real people who administer our
elections and still do
you will hear what they experienced when
the most powerful man in the world the
president of the united states
sought to cling to power after being
voted out of office
by the american people
the system held
but barely
and the system held because people of
courage republicans and democrats like
the witnesses you will hear today
put their oath of to the country and
constitution
above any other consideration
they did their jobs as we must do ours
thank you mr chairman
and i yield back
i now welcome our first panel of
witnesses we're joined today by a
distinguished legislator from arizona
rusty bowers who's a republican speaker
of the arizona house of representatives
mr bowell was first elected to the state
legislature in 1993 and has served as
speaker since 2019.
welcome speaker bowers
brad rashensberger
is the 29th secretary of state of
georgia serving in this role since 2019.
as an elected official and a republican
secretary rasenberger
is responsible for supervising elections
in georgia and maintaining the state's
public records welcome mr secretary
gabriel sterling is the chief operating
officer in the georgia secretary of
state's office mr sterling was the
statewide voting system's implementation
manager for the 2020 election in georgia
responsible for leading the secretary of
state's response to the covet pandemic
and rolling out modernized voting
equipment
i will swear in our witnesses the
witnesses will please stand
and raise their right hand
do you swear uh inform a form on the
penalty of perjury that the testimony
you're about to give is the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth so
help you god
thank you please be seated
let the record reflect that the
witnesses answered in the
affirmative speaker bowers thank you for
being with us today
you're the speaker of the arizona house
and a self-described conservative
republican
you campaigned for president trump and
with him during the 2020 election
is it fair to say that you wanted donald
trump to win a second term in office
please
yes sir thank you
and is it your understanding that
president biden was the winner of the
popular vote in arizona in 2020 yes sir
thank you pursuant to section 5 c 8 of
house resolution 503
the chair recognizes the gentleman from
california mr schiff for questions
speaker bowers thank you for being with
us today um before
we begin with the questions that i have
prepared for you i want to ask you about
a statement
that former president trump issued
which i received just
prior to the hearing
have you had a chance to review that
statement
i my counsel called from arizona and
read it to me yes sir uh in that
statement i won't read it in its
entirety uh former president trump
begins by calling you a rhino uh
republican name only
he then references a conversation
uh in november 2020
in which he claims that you told him
that the election was rigged and that he
had won arizona
to quote the former president during the
conversation
he told me the election was rigged and
that i won arizona unquote
did you have such a conversation with
the president i did have a conversation
with the president
that certainly isn't it
but there were parts of it that are true
but there are parts that are not sir
and the part that i read you uh is that
false
anywhere anyone anytime has said that i
said the election was rigged
that would not be true
and when uh the
former president in his statement today
claimed
that you told him that he won arizona is
that also false
that is also false
mr bowers i understand that after the
election
and i don't know whether this is the
conversation the former president is
referring to
but after the election you received a
phone call from president trump and rudy
giuliani in which they discussed the
result of the presidential election in
arizona
if you would tell us about that call
and whether the former president or mr
giuliani raised allegations of election
fraud
thank you
my wife and i had returned from
attending our church meetings it was on
a sunday
and we were still in the driveway and
i had received a call from a colleague
telling me that the white house was
trying to get in touch with her and i
and that she
said please if you get a call let's try
to
take this together
immediately i saw that the white house
on my bluetooth was calling
and i took the call and was asked by the
i would presume the
operator at the white house if i would
hold for the president which i did and
he mr giuliani came on first
and it's nice at ease
then mr trump president trump then
president trump came on
and
we initiated a conversation
and during that conversation uh did
um you won't ask mr giuliani for proof
of these allegations of fraud that he
was making on multiple occasions yes
and when you asked him uh for evidence
of this frog what did he say
he said that they did have proof and i
asked him do you have names
for example we have two hundred thousand
illegal immigrants some large number
of five or six thousand dead people
etc and i said do you have their names
yes
will you give them to me yes
the president interrupted and said give
the man what he needs rudy he said i i
will and that happened on at least two
occasions that interchange in the
conversation
so mr giuliani was claiming in the call
that there were hundreds of thousands of
undocumented people and thousands of
dead people who had uh purportedly voted
in the election yes
and you asked him for evidence of that i
did
uh and did he ever receive did you ever
receive from him that evidence uh either
during the call after the call or to
this day never
um what was the ask during this call
he was making these allegations of fraud
but he had something or a couple things
uh that they wanted you to do what were
those
the ones i remember were first the
that we would hold that i would
allow an official committee
at at the capitol so that they could
hear this evidence
and that we could take action thereafter
and i refused
i said
up to that time the the circus i called
it circus had been brewing
with uh
lots of demonstrations both at the
counting center at the capitol and other
places
and i didn't want to have that in the
house
i i did not feel that the evidence
granted in its absence
merited
a hearing and i didn't want to be used
as a pawn
uh if there was some other
need that the
that the committee hearing would fulfill
um so that was the first ask that we
hold an official committee hearing and
what was his second ask
i i said to what end
to what end the hearing
he said well we have heard
by an official high up in the republican
legislature
that there is a
legal theory or a legal ability in
arizona
that you can remove the
um
the electors of president biden and
replace them
and we would we would like to have the
legitimate opportunity
through the committee to come to that
end and
and remove that and i said that's
that's something that's totally new to
me i've never heard of any such thing
and he pressed that point and i said
look
you are asking me to do something
that is counter to my oath
when i swore to the constitution to
uphold it and i also swore
to the constitution and the laws of the
state of arizona
and this is totally foreign as an idea
or a
theory to me
and i would never
do anything
of such magnitude without deep
consultation with qualified attorneys
and i said i've got some good attorneys
and i'm going to give you their names
but you're asking me to do something
against my oath and i will not break my
oath
and
i think that was up to that point
um during the conversation uh and you
heard i think when we played um a
snippet of mr giuliani calling other
state legislators and saying that he was
calling us essentially a fellow
republican did he make a similar appeal
to you or bring up the fact that you
shared a a similar party whether it was
in that call or in a later meeting he
did bring that up more than once
and how would he bring that up he would
say
aren't we all republicans here i i would
think we would get a better reception i
mean i would think you would listen a
little more open to my suggestions that
we're all republicans
um
and this uh this evidence that you
asked him for that would justify this
extraordinary step
i think you said they never produced why
did you feel either in the absence of
that evidence
or with it what they were asking you to
do would violate your oath to the
constitution
first of all when the people in arizona
i believe some 40 plus years earlier the
legislature had established the manner
of electing our officials or the
electors for the presidential
race
once it was given to the people
as in bush vigor illustrated by the
supreme court
it becomes a fundamental right of the
people
so as far as i was concerned for someone
to ask me
in the
i would call it a positive there was no
no evidence being
presented of any
strength
evidence can be hearsay evidence it's
still evidence but it's still hearsay
but strong judicial quality evidence
anything
that would say to me
you have a doubt
deny your oath
i will not do that
and
on more than
on more than one occasion throughout all
this that has been brought up
and it is a tenet of my faith
that the constitution is
divinely inspired
of my most basic foundational beliefs
and so for me to do that because
somebody just asked me to
is foreign to my very being i i will not
do it
during that conversation speaker bowers
did you
ask him if what he was proposing had
ever been done before i did and what did
he say
he said well i'm not familiar with
arizona law or any of the laws but i
um
i don't i don't think so
and that also was brought up in other
conversations
both with him and with john eastman and
others
mr speaker bowers i understand that a
week after that call mr giuliani
appeared with others associated with
president trump's effort to overturn
the result of the election at a
purported legislative hearing in a hotel
ballroom in phoenix
was this an official hearing of the
state legislature it was not
and and why was it not a
real or official hearing of the
legislature a legislator can hold a
group meeting you can call it a hearing
but when
they ask me to have an official hearing
we establish it by protocols
public notice
etc
it's typically held at the capitol but
doesn't need to be
we can authorize a hearing off
campus
and in this case i had been asked
on several occasions to allow a hearing
i denied it but said you're free to hold
a meeting any meeting you want to the
person who asked
and which he ultimately did i think he
was a little frustrated but he
ultimately did
this this
meeting was the same day i believe that
the governor of arizona doug ducey
certified biden
as the winner of the presidential
election in arizona
uh did you meet with mr giuliani and his
associates while they were in phoenix
sometime after that purported
legislative hearing at the hotel yes i
did sir
and at that meeting did mr giuliani
raise any specific allegations of
election fraud again
uh his
initial comments were again the litany
of groups of
illegal individuals or
people deceased etc
and he had brought that up and
i wasn't alone in that meeting there are
others and other members of the senate
aggressively questioned him
and then i
proceeded to question him on the proof
that he was going to bring me etc but he
did bring those up yes and these other
legislatures legislators were also
republican members of the senate they
were yes sir
uh and did they also press him for proof
of these allegations uh they pressed him
very strongly
two of them especially very strongly uh
and at some point uh did mr giuliani ask
one of the other attorneys
on his team to help him out with the
evidence he did he asked jenna ellis who
was sitting to his right
one thing was that it was more to the
point of was there sufficient
evidence or action that we could
justify the recalling of the electors
but at that part of the conversation i
know he he referred to someone else but
he did ask do we have the proof to jenna
miss ellis
and she said yes
and i said i want the names you have the
names yes
do you have
how they voted
we have all the information i said can
you get to me
that information did you bring it with
you she
she said no
both
mr giuliani asked her and i asked
generally if they'd brought it with them
she said no it's not with me but we can
get it to you
and i said then you didn't bring me the
evidence
which was repeated in different
iterations for some period of time
at some point did uh one of them uh make
a comment that uh
they didn't have evidence but they had a
lot of theories
that was mr giuliani and what exactly
did he say and how that come up my
recollection he said
we've got lots of theories we just don't
have the evidence
and i don't know if that was a gaff or
maybe he didn't think through what he
said but both myself and others in my
group the three in my group and my my
counsel
both remembered that specifically and
afterwards we kind of laughed about it
and you know getting back to the ask in
that phone call that preceded this
meeting
he wanted you to
[Music]
have the legislature dismiss the biden
electors and replace them with trump
electors on the basis of these theories
of fraud
he did not say it in those exact words
but he did say that he
that arizona law according to what he
understood that that would be allowed
and that we needed to come into session
to take care of that which initiated a
discussion about
again what i can legally and not legally
do and i can't go into session in
arizona unilaterally or on my sole
prerogative
in this meeting or at any other later
time did anyone provide you with
evidence of election fraud sufficient to
affect the outcome of the presidential
election in arizona
no one provided me ever such evidence
the select committee has uncovered
evidence
in the course of our investigation that
had stopped the steel protests at state
capitals across the country
there were individuals with ties to the
groups of parties involved in the
january 6th attack on the u.s capital
one of those incursions took place in
the arizona house of representatives
building as you can see in this footage
this is previously undisclosed video of
protesters illegally entering and
refusing to leave the building
one of the individuals prominently shown
in this video is jacob chansley
perhaps better known as the q on shaman
this rioter entered the capitol on
january 6th
was photographed leaving a threatening
note on the diocese in the u.s senate
chamber and was ultimately sentenced to
41 months in prison after pleading
guilty to obstruction of an official
proceeding
other protesters who occupied the
arizona house of representatives
building included included proud boys
while men armed with rifles stood just
outside the entrance
i understand these protesters were
calling for you by name speaker bowers
is that correct that is correct
speaker bowers did the president call
you again in late uh later in december
he did sir
and did you tell the president in that
second call that you supported him that
you voted for him but that you were not
going to do anything illegal for him i
did sir
nevertheless his lawyer john eastman
called you some days later on june 4th
2021
and he did have a very specific ask that
would have required you to do just what
you had already told the president you
wouldn't do
something that would violate your oath
is that correct that's correct it wasn't
just me i had my counsel and others on
the on the on the call
and what did
dr eastman want you to do
um
that we would
in fact vote take a vote to
overthrow
or i shouldn't say overthrow
that we would decertify the electors and
that that because we had plenary
authority to do so
and
you cited article two section one i
think it's clause two
and uh said that in his opinion that
gave us the authority if there was
i don't recall him saying sufficient
evidence but there was some call or some
strong reason to do so that we or
justification to do so that we could do
that
and that he was asking that we
he his suggestion was that we would do
it and i said
uh again
i took an oath
for me to take that
to do what you do would would be counter
to my oath
i don't recall if it was in that
conversation
clearly that
we talked more about the oath but i said
what would you have me do
and he said
just do it and let the court sort it out
and i said you're asking me
to do something that's never been done
in history
the history of the united states
and i'm going to put my state through
that
without
sufficient proof
and that's going to be good enough with
me
that i would i would put us through that
my state
that i swore to uphold both in
constitution and in law
no sir
he said well that's my suggestion would
be
just just do it and let the courts
figure it all out and i
didn't use that exact phrase but
that was what he his meaning was and i i
declined and i believe that was close to
the end of our phone call
and again this took place after you had
recently spoken with president trump and
told him that you wouldn't do anything
illegal for him is that right it wasn't
days after
obviously it was days after but a few
days had gone by but you had told
president trump you would not do
anything illegal for him i did
both times
and you
told dr eastman that you did not believe
there was legal support to justify what
he was asking but he still wanted you to
do it and effectively let the courts
work it out
i've been warned don't say things you
think maybe he said
but i do remember him saying that the
authority of the legislature was plenary
and that you can do it i said then you
should know that i can't even call the
legislature into session
without a two-thirds majority vote
we're only 30 plus one
i i there's no way that could happen
but in your view what he was asking you
to do would have violated your oath to
the constitution both the united states
constitution and the constitution of the
state of arizona yes sir
did you also receive a call from u.s
representative andy biggs of arizona
on the morning of january 6th i did
and what did mr biggs ask you to do
i believe that was the day that the vote
was occurring
to
each state to have certification
or to declare the certification of the
electors
and he asked if i would
sign on both to a letter that had been
sent from my state
and or that i would support
the decertification of the electors and
i said i would not
mr speaker on december 4th 2020 shortly
after your meeting with rudy giuliani
and other allies of president trump you
released a statement publicly addressing
quote calls for the legislature to
overturn the 2020 certified election
results
the statement is very straightforward in
explaining the quote breathtaking
request unquote made by representatives
of president trump quote that the
arizona legislature overturned the
certified results of last month's
election and deliver the state's
electoral college votes
to president trump unquote
why did you believe as you wrote in this
statement that the rule of law forbid
you from doing what president trump and
his allies wanted you to do
um
representative i'm sorry i should be
saying
mr chairman
of representative schiff
the
um
there's two sides to the answer one is
what am i allowed to do
and what am i forbidden to do
we have no legal
pathway
both in state law nor to my knowledge in
federal law
for us to execute such a request
and i am not allowed to walk or act
beyond my authority
if i'm not specifically authorized as a
legislator as a legislature
then i cannot act
to the point of calling us into session
some say that just a few legislators
have plenty of authority
and that
has come as part of all of this
discussion i'll call it
but so to not have authority and be
forbidden to act beyond my authority on
both counts
i am not authorized to take such action
and that would deny my oath
in your statement you included excerpts
from president ronald reagan's inaugural
address in 1981.
the newly inaugurated president told the
country quote the orderly transfer of
authority is called for in the
constitution
routinely takes place as
as it has for almost two centuries
and few of us stop to think how unique
we really are
in the eyes of many in the world this
every four year ceremony we accept as
normal is nothing less than a miracle
tell us if you would mr speaker why did
you include president reagan's words in
your public statement
um
mr chairman representative schiff
because
i have a lot of admiration for ronald
reagan
i
had the opportunity of going through his
home with one other person and
walking through and
i
have a lot of admiration for him
when he
pointed out which is
i have lived in other country
for a period of time
i have visited a few countries and
during election times
the fact that we
allow an election support an election
and stand behind the election even in
the past when there have been serious
questions about the election
and then move on
without
disturbance
and with acceptance
that we choose
we choose
to follow the outcome of the will of the
people
that will
it means a lot to me and i know it meant
a lot to him and so i think we included
that
thank you speaker bowers
i now want to look even more deeply at
the fake electors scheme
every four years citizens from all over
the united states go to the polls to
elect their president
under our constitution when we cast our
votes for president we are actually
voting to send electors
pledged to our preferred candidate to
the electoral college
in december the electors in each state
meet cast their votes and send those
votes to washington there is only one
legitimate slate of electors from each
state
on the sixth day of january congress
meets in a joint session to count those
votes and the winner of the electoral
college vote becomes the president
in this next segment you'll hear how
president trump and his campaign were
directly involved in advancing and
coordinating
the plot to replace legitimate biden
electors with fake electors not chosen
by the voters
you'll hear how this campaign convinced
these fake electors to cast and submit
their votes through fake certificates
telling them that their votes would only
be used
in the event that president trump won
his legal challenges
yet when the president lost those legal
challenges when courts rejected them as
frivolous and without merit
the fake elector scheme continued
at this point
president trump's own lawyers so-called
team normal
walked away rather than participate in
the plan and his own white house
counsel's office
said that the plan was not
legally sound
let's play the following video produced
by the select committee
my name is casey lucia i'm an
investigative counsel for the house
select committee to investigate the
january 6 attack on the united states
capitol on november 18th a lawyer
working with the trump campaign named
kenneth cheesebro wrote a memo arguing
that the trump campaign should organize
its own electors in the swing states
that president trump had lost the select
committee received testimony that those
close to president trump began planning
to organize fake electors for trump in
states that biden won in the weeks after
the election
who do you remember being involved in
those early discussions around the
thanksgiving time
regarding having alternate electors meet
mr giuliani
several mr giuliani's associates mr
meadows
um
members of congress although it's
difficult to distinguish
if the members i'm thinking of were
involved during thanksgiving or if
they're involved
as we progress through december at the
president's direct request the rnc
assisted the campaign in coordinating
this effort what did the president say
when he called you essentially he turned
the call over to mr eastman who then
proceeded to
talk about the importance of the rnc
helping the campaign gather
these contingent electors in case any of
the legal challenges
that were ongoing change the result
[Music]
more just helping them reach out and
assemble them but the
my understanding is the campaign did
take the lead
and
we just were
helping them in that and that we're all
as president trump and his supporters
continued to lose lawsuits some campaign
lawyers became convinced that convening
electors in states that trump lost was
no longer appropriate
i just remember i either replied or
called somebody saying
unless we have litigation pending that's
like in these states like i don't think
this is appropriate or you know this
isn't the right thing to do
i don't remember how i phrased it but
um
i got into a little bit of a back and
forth and i think it was with ken
cheeseborough um
where i said all right you know
you just get after it like i
i'm out
at that point
um i had
josh finley email mr chesro
politely to say
this is your task
you are responsible for the electoral
college
issues moving forward and this was my
way of taking that responsibility to
zero
the committee learned the white house
counsel's office also felt the plan was
potentially illegal and so to be clear
did you hear the white house counsel's
office say that
um this plan to have alternate electors
meet and cast votes for donald trump in
states that he had lost was not legally
sound
yes sir
and who was present for that meeting
that you remember
mr it was in our office it was mr
meadows mr giuliani and a few of
giuliani's associates the select
committee interviewed several of the
individual fake electors as well as
trump campaign staff who helped organize
the effort we were just you know kind of
kind of useful idiots or rubes at that
point you know a strong part of me
really feels that it's just kind of as
the road continued and as that was fail
your failure failure that that that got
formulated as what we have on the table
let's just do it
and and now after what we've told you
today about the select committee's
investigation about the conclusion of
the professional lawyers on the campaign
staff adjusted clark matt morgan and
josh finley about their unwillingness to
participate in the
convening of these electors
how does that contribute to your
understanding of these issues
i'm i'm
angry
i'm angry
because i think
i think in a sense you know
no one really cared
uh if
if
people were potentially putting
themselves in jeopardy would you have
not wanted to participate in this any
further as well i absolutely would not
have
had i know that the three main lawyers
for the campaign
um that i've spoken to in the past and
were leading up
were were not on board
um
yeah
i was told that
these would only count if a court ruled
in our favor
so that would have been
um using our electors um well would have
been using our electors
in ways that we weren't told about
and we wouldn't have supported
documents obtained by the select
committee indicate that instructions
were given to the electors in several
states that they needed to cast their
ballots in complete secrecy
because this scheme involved fake
electors those participating in certain
states had no way to comply with state
election laws like where the electors
were supposed to meet one group of fake
electors even considered hiding
overnight to ensure that they could
access the state capital as required in
michigan
did mr norton say who he was working
with at all on this effort to have
electors meet
he said he was working with the
president's campaign
he told me
that
the
michigan republican electors were
planning to meet in the capitol
and hide overnight so that they could
fulfill the
role of casting their vote in her law in
the
michigan
chambers
and um i told him in no in certain terms
that that was insane and inappropriate
in one state the fake electors even
asked for a promise that the campaign
would pay their legal fees if they got
sued or charged with a crime ultimately
fake electors did meet on december 14
2020 in arizona georgia michigan
pennsylvania new mexico nevada and
wisconsin at the request of the trump
campaign the electors from these
battleground states signed documents
falsely asserting that they were the
quote duly elected electors from their
state and submitted them to the national
archives and to vice president pence in
his capacity as president of the senate
here is what some of the fake elector
certificates look like as compared to
the real ones
but these ballots had no legal effect
in an email produced to the select
committee dr eastman told a trump
campaign representative that it did not
matter that the electors had not been
approved by a state authority quote the
fact that we have multiple slates of
electors demonstrates the uncertainty of
either that should be enough
he urged that pence act boldly and be
challenged
documents produced to the select
committee show that the trump campaign
took steps to ensure that the physical
copies of the fake elector's electoral
votes from two states were delivered to
washington for january 6.
text messages exchanged between
republican party officials in wisconsin
show that on january 4th the trump
campaign asked for someone to fly their
fake electors documents to washington
a staffer for wisconsin senator ron
johnson texted a staffer for vice
president pence just minutes before the
beginning of the joint session
this staffer stated that senator johnson
wished to hand deliver to the vice
president the fake electors votes from
michigan and wisconsin the vice
president's aide unambiguously
instructed them not to deliver the fake
votes to the vice president even though
the fake electric slates were
transmitted to congress and the
executive branch the vice president held
firm in his position that his role was
to count lawfully submitted electoral
votes joseph r biden jr
of the state of delaware has received
306 votes
donald j trump of the state of florida
has received 232 votes which is what he
did when the joint session resumed on
january 6 after the attack on the
capital
what we just heard in that video was an
aide to the white house chief of staff
telling this committee that the white
house counsel's office felt that this
fake electors plan was not legally sound
nevertheless the trump campaign went
forward with the scheme anyway
speaker bowers were you aware that fake
electors had met in phoenix on december
14th and purported to cast electoral
votes for president trump i was not
when you learned that these electors had
met and sent their electoral votes to
washington what did you think
well
i thought of the book the gang that
couldn't shoot straight
and
i just thought
this is a
this is a tragic parody
mr bowers i understand that as you flew
from phoenix to washington yesterday
you reflected upon some passages from a
personal journal that you were keeping
in december 2020 while all this was
taking place
uh with your permission i'm wondering if
you would be willing to share one
passage in particular with us
thank you very much
it is painful to have friends
who have been such a help to me
turn on me with such rancor
i may in the eyes of men
not hold correct opinions or act
according to their vision or convictions
but i do not take this current situation
in a light manner
a fearful manner
or a vengeful manner
i do not want to be a winner by cheating
i will not play with laws i swore
allegiance to
with any contrived desire towards
deflection
of my deep foundational desire
to follow god's will
as i believe
he led my conscience to embrace
how else
will i ever approach him
in the wilderness of life
knowing that i ask of this guidance only
to show myself a coward
in defending the course he let me take
he led me to take
thank you mr speaker those are powerful
words
i understand that taking the courageous
positions that you did
following the 2020 election
in defense of the rule law and
protecting the voters of arizona
resulted in you and your family being
subjected to protests and terrible
threats
can you tell us how this impacted you
and your family
well
as others in the videos have mentioned
we received
my secretaries would say
in excess of twenty thousand emails and
tens of thousands of voicemails and
texts
which
saturated our offices and we are unable
to work
at least communicate
but at home
um
up till even recently
it is the new
pattern or a pattern in our lives to
worry what will happen on saturdays
because we have
various groups come by
and
they have had
video panel trucks with videos of me
proclaiming me to be a pedophile and a
pervert and a corrupt and
politician
and
blaring
uh
loudspeakers in my neighborhood
and
leaving literature both on my
property but
arguing and threatening with neighbors
and with myself
um
and i don't know if i should name groups
but there was a one gentleman that had
the three bars on his chest
and he had a pistol
and was threatening of my neighbor not
with the pistol but just vocally
when i saw the gun i knew i had to get
close
and
at the same time
on some of these
we had
a daughter who was gravely ill
who was upset
by
what was happening outside
and my wife that
was a valiant person very
very strong
quiet very strong woman
so it was disturbing
this is disturbing
mr speaker i want to thank you
for your service the state of arizona
and to the country
mr chairman at this point i think it'd
be appropriate to take a short recess
accordingly i reserve the balance of my
time
the chair requests that those
in the hearing room remain seated until
the capitol police have escorted members
and witnesses from the room
we'll have
five minutes
five minute recess
okay
see you
down
so
oh
i
hey
all right
yes
testifying
is
good
oh
and
jesus
please
this place
what's up
uh
so
time
she
so
foreign
oh
okay
um
uh
[Music]
the committee will be in order
president trump's pressure campaign
against state officials
existed in all the key battleground
states that he lost
but the former president had a
particular obsession with georgia
here is the president on the afternoon
of january 6th
after his own attorney general warned
him that the claims you are about to
hear
are patently false
we should find those votes
they should absolutely find that
[Music]
just over 11 000 votes that's all we
need
they defrauded us out of a win in
georgia and we're not going to forget it
so the state of georgia is where we will
turn our attention to next
i want to emphasize that our
investigation into these issues is still
ongoing
as i stated in our last hearing if you
have relevant information or documentary
evidence to share with the select
committee
we welcome your cooperation
but we will share some of our findings
with you today
secretary rassenberger
thank you for being here today
you've been a public servant in georgia
since 2015
serving first as a member of the georgia
house of representatives and then since
january 2019
as georgia's secretary of state
as a self-described conservative
republican it is is it fair to say that
you wanted president trump to win the
2020 election
yes it is
the secretary many witnesses have told
the select committee
that election day november 3rd 2020 was
a largely uneventful date in their home
states
in spite of the challenges of conducting
an election doing a pandemic
you wrote in the washington post that
election was quote successful
tell us
what was your impression of how election
day had proceeded in georgia
on election day in november
our election went remarkably smooth
in fact we meet at the gma headquarters
that's the georgia energy um emergency
management association uh meeting
location but we are following wait times
in line in the afternoon our average
wait time was three minutes statewide
that we were recording for various
precincts and it actually got down to
two minutes
and at the end of the day we felt that
we had a successful election from the
standpoint of the administration and the
operation of the election
thank you the chair recognized the
gentleman from california mr shield
thank you mr chairman
secretary raffensberger did joe biden
win the 2020 presidential election in
georgia and by what margin
uh
president biden carried the state of
georgia by approximately 12 000 votes
and mr secretary as i understand it your
office took several steps to ensure the
accuracy of the vote count in georgia
reviewing the vote count in at least
three different ways
these steps included a machine recount a
forensic audit and a full hand recount
of every one of the five million ballots
cast
did these efforts including a recount of
literally every ballot cast in the state
of georgia confirmed the result yes they
did we counted the abouts where the
first tabulation would be scanned then
when we did our 100
hand audit of the entire all 5 million
ballots in the state of georgia i'll
cast in place all absentee ballots they
were all hand recounted and they came
remarkably close to the first count and
then upon the election being certified
president trump because he was in within
half percent
excuse me could ask for
every account and then we recounted them
again through the scanners and we got
remarkably the same count three counts
all remarkably close which showed that
president trump did come up short
nevertheless as you will see the
president and his allies began making
began making numerous false allegations
of voter fraud
false allegations that you and mr
sterling among others had to address
mr sterling thank you also for being
here today
following the 2020 election in addition
to your normal duties i understand that
you became a spokesperson to try to
combat disinformation about the election
and the danger it was creating for
elections officials among others
in a december one press conference you
addressed some of your remarks directly
to president trump
let's take a look at what you said that
day
mr president
it looks like you likely lost the state
of georgia
we're investigating there's always a
possibility i get it you have the rights
to go through the courts what you don't
have the ability to do and you need to
step up and say this is stop inspiring
people to commit potentialize to
violence someone's going to get hurt
someone's going to get shot someone's
going to get killed
and it's not right
i
[Music]
it's not right
mr sean what prompted you to make these
remarks
mr schiff we had had a previously
scheduled press conference that day as
we were in the habit of doing trying to
be as transparent as we could about the
election in the accounts going on
um a little after lunch that day
uh lunchtime i received a call from the
project manager from dominion voting
systems
who
was oddly audibly shaken she's not the
kind of person i would assume would be
that way she has a master's from mit a
graduate of naval academy and was very
much on the ball
pretty unflappable
and she informed me about a young
contractor they had who had been
receiving threats
um from a video been posted by some q
anon supporters
and at that point we had been sort of
been steeping in this kind of stuff so
we were it was around us all the time so
i didn't take note of it
more than adding to the pile of other
stuff we were having to deal with
and
i did pull up twitter and i scrolled
through it and i saw the young man's
name there was a particular tweet that
for like a better word was a straw that
broke the camel's back
um
had a young man's name
it was a very unique name i believe he's
a first generation american
and he said had his name
you committed treason
may god have mercy on your soul with a
slowly twisting
gif of a noose
and for lack of a better word i lost it
i just got irate
my boss was with me at the time the
deputy secretary jordan feusch and she
could tell that i was angry i'm turning
i tend to turn red from here up when
that happens and that happened at that
time
and she called secretary raffesburger to
say we're seeing these kind of threats
and
gabe thinks we need to say something
about it and secretary said yes and
that's what prompted me to do what
i did i lost my temper
but it seemed necessary at the time
because it was just getting worse and i
don't i could not tell you why that
particular one was the one that put me
over the edge but it did now after you
made this plea to the president did
donald trump urge his supporters to
avoid the use of violence
that's my knowledge
now as we know the president was aware
of your speech because he tweeted about
it later that day let's take a look at
what the president said
in the tweet
donald trump claims that there was quote
massive voter fraud in georgia
mr sterling that was just plain false
wasn't it
yes sir
nevertheless the very next day on
december 2nd president trump released a
lengthy video again making false claims
of election fraud in georgia
let's take a look at what he said this
time
they found thousands and thousands of
votes
that were out of whack
all against me
in fact the day after donald trump
released that video so now we're talking
just two days after the emotional
warning that you gave that someone's
going to get killed
representatives of president trump
appeared in georgia including rudy
giuliani
and launched a new conspiracy theory
that would take on a life of its own and
threatened the lives of several innocent
election workers
this story falsely alleges that sometime
during election night
election workers at the state farm arena
in atlanta georgia
kicked out poll observers
after the observers left the story goes
these workers pulled so-called suitcases
of ballots from under a table and ran
those ballots through counting machines
multiple times
completely without evidence president
trump and his allies claimed that these
suitcases
contained as many as eighteen thousand
ballots all for joe biden
none of this was true
but rudy giuliani appeared before the
georgia state senate and played a
surveillance video from state farm arena
falsely claiming that it showed this
conspiracy taking place
here's a sample of what mr giuliani had
to say during that hearing
and when you look at what you saw on the
video which to me with a smoking gun
powerful smoking gun
well i don't
don't have to be a genius to figure out
what happened
and i don't have to be a genius to
figure out that those votes are not
legitimate votes
you don't put legitimate votes under a
table no
wait until you throw the opposition out
and in the middle of the night count
them
we would have to be fools to think that
president trump's campaign amplified
giuliani's false testimony in a tweet
pushing out the video footage
giuliani likewise pushed out his
testimony on social media
as you can see in this tweet mr giuliani
wrote that it was quote now beyond doubt
unquote that fulton county democrats had
stolen the election
later in this hearing we'll hear
directly from one of the election
workers in this video about the effect
these lies had on her
and on her family
mr sterling did the investigators in
your office review the entire
surveillance tape from the state farm
arena on election night
uh they actually
reviewed approximately 48 hours going
over the time period where action was
taking place at the um accounting center
at state farm arena
and what did the tape actually show
depending on which time you want to
start because as was mentioned this
conspiracy theory took on a life of its
own
where they conflated a water main break
that wasn't a water main break and
throwing observers out and a series of
other things what it actually showed was
fulton county election workers engaging
in normal ballot processing
one of the specific things
one of the things was very frustrating
was the so-called
suitcases of ballots from under the
table
if you watched the entirety of the video
you saw that these were election workers
who were under the impression they were
going to get to go home around 10 10 30.
people are putting on their coats
they're putting ballots that are
prepared to be scanned
into ballot carriers that are then
sealed with tamper-proof seals so that
they can you know they're not messed
with
um
and
it's an interesting thing because you
watch all there's four screens of the
video and as you're watching it you can
see the election monitors in the corner
with the press as they're taking these
ballot carriers and putting them under
the under the table you see it there
one of the other hidden ones if you look
at the actual tape was on the outside of
the table just from the camera angle you
couldn't see it originally
and this goes under the no good deed
goes unpunished we were told that we
were at jima as the secretary pointed
out and we were under we were told that
it looked like they were shutting down
with fulton county accounting the
secretary expressed some displeasure at
that because we wanted to keep everybody
keep counting so we could get to the
results and know what was happening
so our elections director called their
elections director who was at another
location because this was election day
there was two different places where
ballot things were being done by the
fulton county office
um
so he called the elections dragon fulton
then called ralph jones who was at the
state farm arena and said
what the heck are you doing go ahead and
stay
as you watch the video itself you see
him take the phone call as people are
putting things away and getting ready to
leave
and you can tell for about 15-20 seconds
he does not want to tell these people
they have to stay he walks over he
thinks about it for a second you see him
come back to the corner of a desk and
kind of slumps his shoulders says okay
y'all we got to keep on counting and
then you see him take their coats off
get the ballots out and then a secondary
thing that you'll see on there is you'll
have people who are counting ballots
who a batch will go through
they will take them off and run that
through again what happens there is a
standard operating procedure if there is
a miss scan if there's a misalignment if
it doesn't read right these are high
speed high capacity scanners so three or
four will go through after a miss scan
you have to delete that batch and put it
back through again
and by going through the hand tally as
secretary pointed out
we showed that if had there been
multiple ballots scanned without a
corresponding physical ballot your
accounts would have been a lot higher
than the ballots themselves and by doing
the hand tally
we saw two specific numbers that were
met the hand tally got us to a point one
zero five three percent off of the total
votes cast and point zero zero nine nine
percent on the margin which is
essentially dead on accurate um most
academic studies say on a hand towel
you'll have between one and two percent
but because we use ballot marking
devices where it's very clear
what the voter intended made it a lot
easier to us forced to conduct that hand
count and show that none of that was
true
now i understand that
when you reviewed these tapes and did
the analysis it disproved this
conspiracy theory
um but you still had to take a lot of
steps to try to make sure the public
knew the truth about these allegations
uh and you did frequent uh briefings for
the press
let's take a look at one of those press
briefings so mr sterling that you held
on december 7th
uh to make the point that you just did
today
move on to what i'm going to call
disinformation monday
out of the gate
many of y'all saw the video take from
state farm arena i spent hours with our
post-certified investigators uh justin
gray from wsb spent hours with us going
over this video to explain to people
that what you saw
the secret suitcases with magic ballots
were actually ballots that had been
patched into those
absentee ballot carriers
by the workers in plain view of the
monitors and the press
and what's really frustrating is the
president's attorneys had this same
videotape
they saw the exact same things the rest
of us could see and they chose to
mislead state senators and the public
about what was on that video
i'm quite sure that they will not
characterize the video if they try to
enter into evidence because that is the
kind of thing that could lead to
sanctions
because it's obviously untrue they knew
it was untrue and they continue to do
things like this
mr sterling despite the efforts by your
office to combat this misinformation
misinformation by speaking out publicly
and through local media
you were unable to match the reach of
president trump's platform and social
media megaphone
spreading these false conspiracy
theories
what was it like to compete with a
president who had the biggest bully
pulpit in the world to push out these
false claims
for lack of a better word it was
frustrating
but oftentimes i felt
our information was getting out but that
there was a
reticence
of people who needed to believe it to
believe it because
the president united states whom many
looked up to and respected was telling
them it wasn't true
despite the facts
and
i have characterized at one point it was
kind of like a shovel trying to empty
the ocean
and yes it was frustrating i even have
you know family members
who i had to argue with about some of
these things and i would show them
things and
the problem you have is you're getting
to people's hearts
i remember there's one specific an
attorney that we know that we show to
walk him through this wasn't true okay i
get that this wasn't true okay i get
that this wasn't five or six things but
at the end he goes i just know in my
heart that cheated
i said so once you get past the heart
the facts don't matter as much
and
our job
from our point of view is to get the
facts out do our job tell the truth
follow the constitution follow the law
and defend the institutions
and the institutions held
let's take a look at what you were
competing with this is former the former
president speaking in georgia on
december 5th
of fraud is overwhelming and again i'm
going to ask you to look up at that very
very powerful and very expensive screen
hidden cases of possible ballots or
rolled out from under a table four
people under a cloud of suspicion
so
if you just take the crime
of what those democrats workers were
doing and by the way there was no water
main break you know they said there was
there was no border paper
that's ten times more than i need
to win this state ten times more
it's ten times maybe more than that but
it's ten times more
because we lost by a very close number
this committee's hearing last monday we
heard from senior federal law
enforcement officials
from the senior most
federal law enforcement official in
atlanta at the time
u.s attorney for the northern district
b.j pack as well as former attorney
general bill barr
they both testified that the allegations
were thoroughly investigated and found
to have no merit here is u.s attorney
pack
it goes to attorney general i told him
that we looked into it we've done uh
several things including uh interviewing
the witnesses i listened to the the
tapes and reviewed the uh videotape
myself
and that um there was nothing there um
giuliani was wrong in representing that
this was uh
suitcase full of balance
and here's what attorney general bill
barr had to say about the same
allegations
took a look hard look at this ourselves
and based on our uh review of it
including the interviews of the key
witnesses
the fulton county
allegations were had no merit
we also have testimony from senior
department of justice officials
establishing
that they specifically told president
trump these allegations had been
thoroughly investigated and were
completely
without merit here's acting attorney
deputy attorney general richard donahue
describing a phone conversation in which
he specifically told president trump
that these allegations were false
i think kept fixating on this suitcase
that supposedly had fraudulent ballots
that the suitcase was rolled out from
under the table
and i said no sir there is no suitcase
you can watch that video over and over
there is no suitcase there is a wheeled
bin
where they came
where they carry the ballots
no matter how many times senior
department of justice officials
including his own attorney general told
the president that these allegations
were not true
president trump kept promoting these
lies and putting pressure on state
officials to accept them on january 2nd
the president had a lengthy telephone
conversation with secretary
raffensberger
prior to the president's call though i
want to share a bit of important context
first the white house
including the former president's chief
of staff
mark meadows
repeatedly called or texted the
secretary's office
some 18 times in order to set up this
call
they were quite
persistent
second chief of staff mark meadows took
the extraordinary step of showing up at
a signature audit site in georgia
where he met with secretary
raffensberger's chief investigator
francis watson who was supervising that
audit process
behind me is a photograph from that
visit
third the day after meadows georgia
visit he set up a call between president
trump and francis watson
on the call between president trump and
georgia investigator francis watson the
former president continued to push the
false claim that he'd won the state of
georgia let's listen to that part of the
conversation
you know it's just you have the most
important job in the country right now
because if we win georgia first of all
if we win you're gonna have two wins
they're not gonna win right now you know
they're down
because
the people of georgia are so angry at
what happened to me they know i won one
by hundreds of thousands of votes it
wasn't close
and in this next clip he told the state
law enforcement official that she'd be
praised
if she found
the right answer
hopefully
you know i will
when when the right answer comes out
you'd be praised i mean i don't know why
you know they've made it so hard
anything will be praised people will say
great
because that's what it's about that
ability to check into
and to make it right because everyone
knows it's wrong there's just no way
mr raffensberger i know you weren't on
this call but but that you have listened
to it
president trump didn't win by hundreds
of thousands of votes in georgia did he
no he did not uh i've been traveling
through the state of georgia for a year
now and
i simply put in a nutshell
what happened in the fall of 2020
is that 28 000 georgians skipped the
presidential race
and yet they voted down ballot in other
races
and the republican congressmen ended up
getting 33 000 more votes than president
trump and that's why president trump
came up short
thank you mr secretary
the president on this call doesn't stop
here
let's listen to another part of the
conversation between president trump and
ms watson
anyway but whatever you can do francis
it would be uh it's a great thing it's
an important thing for the country so
important you have no idea it's so
important
and i very much appreciate it
whatever you can do francis this is the
president of the united states
calling an investigator looking into the
election in which he is a candidate
and asking her to do whatever you can do
mr secretary
you place this call to your chief
investigator on september 23rd 2020. the
select committee has received text
messages indicating that mark meadows
wanted to send some of the investigators
in her office
in the words of one white house aide a
shitload of potus stuff including coins
actual autographed maga hats etcetera
white house staff intervened to make
sure that didn't happen
it was clear at the time of this call
that the former president had his sights
set on january 6th
listen to this portion when he told
francis watson about a very important
date
do you think they'll be working after
christmas
which is a very important date
important date of course was the joint
session of congress where george's
electoral votes would be counted for joe
biden
a little a little over a week after this
call to francis watson
the president was finally able to speak
with you secretary raffettsberger
bear in mind as we discussed this call
today that by this point in time early
january the election in georgia had
already been certified
but perhaps more important the president
of the united states had already been
polled repeatedly
by his own top justice department
officials that the claims he was about
to make to you about massive fraud in
georgia were completely false
mr secretary the call between you and
the president lasted 67 minutes over an
hour
we obviously can't listen to the entire
recording here today although it is
available on the select committee's
website but we'll listen to selected
excerpts of it now so that we can get
your insights
let's begin with the president raising
the thoroughly debunked allegations
of suitcases of ballots
in an official voter box they were in
what looked to be uh
suitcases or trunks
suitcases but they weren't in uh
in voter boxes
uh the minimum number it could be
because we watched it and they they
watched it
certified
uh in slow motion
instant replay if you can believe it but
they had slow motion and it was
magnified many times over
and the minimum it was was 18 000
ballots all for biden
these are the allegations that the
department of justice the attorney
general the georgia bureau of
investigation and your office heads all
said
were false is that right
correct and even more importantly
when bj pack resigned as u.s attorney of
the northern district
president trump appointed as acting u.s
attorney the northern district bobby
christine
and bobby christine looked at that and
he was quoting the ajc that he found
nothing and he dismissed that case early
on
thank you mr secretary the president
references suitcases or trunks
mr sterling were the objects seen in
these videos suitcases or trunks or were
they just the ordinary containers that
are used by election workers they're
staying at standard ballot carriers that
allow for seals to be put on them so
they're tamper proof
and finally the president claims that
there was a minimum of eighteen thousand
ballots
somehow smuggled in all for biden i take
it uh gentlemen that that was also
categorically false
there's no a there's no physical way he
could know who those ballots were for
but secondarily
we had
fulton county for years has been an
issue in our state when it comes to
elections so we had they had a very
difficult time during the primary in
large part because of covet so we had
put them under a consent decree the
secretary got negotiated where we had a
monitor
on site and his name was carter jones
and he took a notation
he had gone from state farm to the
english street warehouse to look at
election day activities but before he
left the state farm arena he noted
how many balls have been counted on each
one of the machines
and when he
came back after we found out they were
working again
he took note again when they closed and
i believe the final number was something
around 8 900 total battles were scanned
from the time he left to the time about
12 30 or 1 o'clock in the morning so way
below 18 000.
let's play the next clip
i heard it was close i said there's no
way
but they dropped a lot of votes in there
late at night you know that brad
mr secretary did somebody drop drop a
lot of votes there late at night
no
i believe that the president was
referring to some of the counties when
they would upload but the ballots had
all been accepted and had to be accepted
by state law by 7 pm so there were no
additional ballots accepted after 7 pm
let's play the next clip in which the
president makes claims about so-called
dead voters
the other thing dead people so dead
people voted
and i think uh the the number is in the
pro close to 5 000 people
and they went to uh obituaries they went
to uh all sorts of methods to come up
with an accurate number and a minimum is
close to about 5 000 voters
so secretary did your office investigate
whether those allegations were accurate
did 5 000 dead people in georgia vote
uh no it's not accurate actually in
their lawsuits they allege 10 315 dead
people
we found two dead people when i wrote my
letter to congress that stated january 6
and subsequent to that we found two more
that's one two three four people not
four thousand but just a total of four
not ten thousand not five thousand
okay let's play the next clip
and there's nothing wrong with saying
that you know uh
that you've recalculated because
uh
the 2000 236 and absentee ballots i mean
they're all exact
numbers that were were done by
accounting firms law firms etc
and even if you cut them in half cut
them in half and cut them in half again
it's more votes than we need
mr secretary is there any way that you
could have lawfully changed the result
in the state of georgia
and somehow explained it away as a
recalculation
no the numbers are the numbers the
numbers don't lie
we had many allegations and we
investigated every single one of them
but i challenged my team did we miss
anything
they said that there was over 66 000
underage voters we found that there's
actually zero you can register to vote
in georgia when you're 17 and a half you
have to be 18 by election day we checked
that out every single voter they said
that there's 2423 non-registered voters
there were zero they said that there was
2056 felons we identified less than 74
or less that were actually still in
felony sentence every single allegation
we checked we ran down the rabbit trail
to make sure that our numbers were
accurate
so there's no way you could have
recalculated except uh
by fudging the numbers
the numbers were the numbers and we
could not recalculate because we had
made sure that we had checked every
single allegation and we had many
investigations we had nearly 300 from
the 2020 election
mr secretary you trying to push back
when the president made these
unsupported claims whether they were
about suitcases of ballots
or that biden votes were counted three
times let's play the next clip
accident they did not put that we
can we did an audit of that and we've
proved conclusively that they were not
scanned three times yep mr president
we'll send you the link from wsb that
doesn't i don't care about a link i
don't need it i have a lot of much
brand i have a much better list
you told the president you would send
him a link from wsb which i understand
is a local television station that had
a uh unedited video from the state farm
arena
but the president wasn't interested in
that he said he had a much better link
mr secretary
at the time that you were on the call
with the president as we have shown both
the fbi and the georgia bureau of
investigation
have proven these claims to be nonsense
and you told him about these
investigations on the phone let's listen
to what president trump had to say about
the state and federal law enforcement
officers
who conducted who investigated these
false claims
there's no way they could then they're
incompetent
they're either dishonest
okay there's only two answers dishonesty
or incompetence there's just no way look
there's no way
but the president didn't stop at
insinuating that law enforcement
officers were either dishonest or
incompetent
he went on to suggest that you could be
subject to criminal liability for your
role in the matter
before i play that portion of the
conversation i'd like to show you
something that the president retweeted a
couple weeks before your call with him
here's the president retweeting a post
from one of his allies a lawyer who was
later sanctioned by a judge in michigan
for making false claims of election
fraud
let's take a look at that tweet
the tweet read quote president trump at
real donald trump is a genuinely good
man
he does not really like to fire people i
bet he dislikes putting people in jail
especially quote unquote republicans
he gave at brian kemp georgia and at
georgia secretary of state every chance
to get it right they refused
they will soon be going to jail
so on your call this was not the first
time the president was suggesting you
might be criminally liable
with that let's listen to this portion
of the call
i think you're going to find that they
are shredding ballots because they have
to get rid of the ballots because the
ballots are unsigned the ballots are are
corrupt
and they're brand new and they don't
have seals and there's a whole thing
with the ballots but the ballots are
corrupt and you're going to find that
they are which is totally illegal it's
it's it's more illegal for you than it
is for them because you know what they
did and you're not reporting it that's a
you know that's a criminal that's a
criminal offense
and and you know you can't let that
happen that's that's a big risk to you
and to ryan
your lawyer that's a big risk
secretary robertsburg after making a
false claim about shredding a ballots
the president suggested
that you may be committing a crime by
not going along with his claims of
election fraud
and after suggesting that you might have
criminal exposure
president trump makes his most explicit
ask
of the call
let's play a part of that conversation
so look all i want to do is this i just
want to find
11
780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state
mr secretary was the president here
asking you for exactly what he wanted
one more vote than his opponent
what i knew is that we didn't have any
votes to find we had continued to look
we investigated like i just shared the
numbers with you there were no votes to
find that was an accurate count that had
been certified
and as our general counsel said there
was no shredding of ballots
mr secretary after making this request
the president then goes back to the
danger of having you deny these
allegations of fraud let's listen to
that part of the clip
and i watched you this morning and you
said uh
well there was no criminality but i i
mean all of this stuff is is very
dangerous stuff when you talk about no
criminality i think it's very dangerous
for you to say that
secretary robertsburger you wrote about
this in your book
and you said quote
i felt then and still believe today that
this was a threat others obviously
thought so too
because some of trump's more radical
followers have responded as if it was
their duty to carry out this threat
please tell us what you your wife even
your daughter-in-law experienced
regarding threats from trump's more
radical followers
well after the
after the election
uh
my
email my cell phone was doxxed and so i
was getting texts all over the country
and then eventually my wife started
getting the
text and hers typically came in as
sexualized attacks which were disgusting
you have to understand that trish and i
we met in high school we were married
over 40 years now and so um they started
going after her i think just to probably
put pressure on me my case just quit
walk away
and so that happened
and then some people broke into my
daughter-in-law's home and
my son has passed and she's a widow
and she has two kids and so we're very
concerned about her safety also
mr secretary why didn't you just quit
and walk away
because i knew that we had followed the
law and we followed the constitution
and i think sometimes moments require
you to stand up and
and just take the shots you're doing
your job and that's all we did
you know we just followed the law we
followed the constitution
and at the end of the day president
trump came up short but i had to be
faithful to the constitution
and that's what i saw an oath to do
during the remainder of the call the
former president continued to press you
to find the remaining votes that would
ensure his victory in georgia let's
listen to a little more
why wouldn't you want to find the right
answer brad instead of keep saying that
the numbers are right
so look uh can you get together tomorrow
and brad we just want the truth it's
simple and uh
and everyone's going to look very good
if the truth comes out it's okay it
takes a little while but let the truth
come out
and the truth the real truth is i won by
400 000 votes at least so what so what
are we going to do here folks i only
need 11 000 votes fellas i need 11 000
votes give me a break
four days after the president's call to
secretary raffenberger was january 6th
the president whipped up the crowd in
front of the ellipse once again
promoting the allegation that secretary
raffesburger the president's own
attorney general
had told him was false
here he is on the ellipse
in fulton county republican poll
watchers were ejected in some cases
physically
from the room under the false pretense
of a pipe burst water main burst
everybody leave which we now know was a
total lie
then
election officials
pull boxes democrats and suitcases of
ballots out from under a table you all
saw it in television totally fraudulent
and illegally scanned them for nearly
two hours totally unsupervised
tens of thousands of votes this act
coincided with a mysterious vote dump
of up to one
000 votes for joe biden
almost none for trump oh that sounds
fair that was at 1 34 a.m
mr secretary mr sterling i want to thank
you for your service to the state of
georgia and to the country
speaker bowers likewise i want to thank
you for your service to the state of
arizona and to the country you have
served not only your home states
but our nation and our democracy
mr chairman i yield back
thank you mr schiff i thank you
witnesses for joining us today
you are now dismissed
so
thank
[Music]
cool
i now welcome our found witness this
afternoon
andreas shea moss
miss moss worked in the department of
registration
and elections in fulton county georgia
from 2017 until 2022
in that job ms moss handled voter
applications and absentee ballot
requests and also helped to process the
vote count for several elections
in december 2020
miss moss and her mother
miss ruby freeman became the target of
nasty lies spread by president trump and
his allies as they sought to overturn
the election results in georgia
miss moss and her mother miss freeman
are two of the unsung heroes in this
country doing the hard work of keeping
our democracy functioning for every
american
miss moss
welcome
thank you for your service and i thank
you for being here today
i will now swear you in please stand
do you swear our affirm on the penalty
of perjury that the testimony you're
about to give is the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
you god
thank you please be seated
let your record reflect that the witness
answered in the affirmative
miss walk miss moss thank you very much
for being here today
i understand that you are here
along with your mother today
uh would you like to introduce your mama
hi mom
uh miss moss
today we'll be asking you about some of
the threats that you receive following
the 2020 election
since you've been an election worker for
over 10 years
i want to ask you
in your decade of service
had you ever experienced threats like
these before
don't be nervous just i understand
so
uh and
i want to make sure that the record
reflects that you've done it
for quite a while and you never received
the threats and your answer was no
thank you
pursuant to section 5 c8
of the house resolution 503
the chair recognizes the gentleman from
california mr schiff for questions
good afternoon ms moss thank you for
being here
i understand that you were employed by
the fulton county registration elections
department for more than 10 years
and i understand that you love that job
please tell us what made you so fond of
the work that you did
[Music]
well
i've always
been told by my grandmother how
important it is to vote and how
people before me a lot of people older
people my family did not have that right
so
what i loved most
about my job were the older voters
younger people could usually do
everything from their phone or go online
but
the older voters like to call they like
to talk to you they like to get my card
they like to know that every election
i'm here
and like even college students a lot of
parents
trust in me to make sure their child
does not have to drive home
they'll get an absentee ballot they can
vote and
i really found pleasure in that i like
being the one that
you know if someone can't navigate
my voter page or you know they want a
new precinct card and they don't have a
copy machine or computer or all of that
i could put it in the mail for them um
i was excited always about sending out
all the absentee ballots for the elderly
disabled people
i even remember driving to an
hospital
to
give someone her absentee application um
that's that's what i love the most
so you really enjoyed helping people
vote and participate and
uh and that was something
the right to vote that your grandmother
taught you was precious yes
well i know the events that we're here
to talk about today are incredibly
difficult to relive
your proud service as an election worker
took a dramatic turn on the day that
rudy giuliani publicized the video
of you and your mother counting ballots
on election night
president trump rudy giuliani and others
claimed on the basis of this video that
you and your mother were somehow
involved in a plot
to kick out observers bring suitcases of
false ballots for biden into the arena
and then run them through the machines
multiple times
none of that was true was it none of it
i'd like to show you some of the
statements that rudy giuliani made in a
second hearing before the georgia state
legislators
a week after that video clip from state
farm arena was first circulated
by mr giuliani and president trump
i want to advise viewers that these
statements are completely false
and also deeply disturbing
tape earlier in the day
of ruby freeman and shea freeman morris
and one other gentleman
quite obviously surreptitiously passing
around
usb ports as if they are vials of heroin
or cocaine
i mean it's our state it's obvious to
anyone who's a criminal investigator or
prosecutor they are engaged in
surrenderitious illegal activity again
that day
and that's a week ago
and they're still walking around georgia
lying
should have been they should have been
uh should have been questioned already
uh their places of work their homes
should have been searched for evidence
of balance trail evidence of usb ports
for evidence of voter fraud
that video was from rudy giuliani's
appearance at a georgia state senate
hearing
on december 10.
how did you become aware how did you
first become aware that rudy giuliani
president's lawyer was accusing you and
your mother of a crime
i was at work like always um
and
the former chief mr jones asked me to
come to his office and
um when i went to his office the former
director mr barron was in there
and
they showed me a video
on their computer
um
it was just like a very short clip of
us working at state farm and it had
someone on the video like talking
um
over the video just
saying that we were doing things that we
weren't supposed to do just
lying um
throughout the video
and that's when i first
found out about it
and were there social media posts uh
that they showed you
responding to those false claims
well um
when i saw the video of course the first
thing that i said was like why what why
is why are they doing this what's going
on
and um they you know just told me that
trump his allies were not
satisfied with the outcome of the
election
and
they they were getting a lot of threats
and
um
being harassed online and asked me you
know have i been receiving anything and
i need to check on my mom
and
i told them um you know i was like
where where have they
you know where have you been getting
these threats i i don't believe i have
any and
um mr jones told me like they're
attacking his
uh facebook and i don't really use
facebook i have one so i went to the
facebook app and i'm just kind of
panicky at this point because this has
never happened to me and my mom is
involved and i'm like her only child
so i'm just asking him like where are
the messages all i see is the feeds like
how do you get to the messages and he
said it's another icon on your phone
that says messenger
and i went to that icon and
it was just a lot of horrible things
there
and those horrible things that they
include threats
yes a lot of threats um
wishing death upon me
telling me that you know i'm i'll be in
jail with my mother and
saying things like
be glad it's 2020 and not 1920.
that's
yeah
were a lot of these threats and and vile
comments racist in nature
a lot of them were racist a lot of them
were just hateful
um yes sir
in one of the videos we just watched mr
giuliani accused you and your mother are
passing some sort of usb drive
to each other
uh what was your mom actually handing
you on that video
a ginger mint
it wasn't just rudy giuliani
we heard president trump make these
false allegations
repeatedly during his call with
secretary raffensberger
let's listen to
a portion of what he had to say about
you and your mother
we had
at least 18 000 that's on tape we had
them counted
very
painstakingly 18 000 voters
uh having to do with ruby freeman that's
she's a vote scammer a professional vote
scammer and
hustler
donald trump attacked you and your
mother using her name 18 times on that
call
18 times
mr moss can you describe what you
experienced listening to former
president trump attack you and your
mother
in a call with the georgia secretary of
state
i felt horrible
i felt like it was all my fault like if
i would have never
decided to be an elections worker like
i could have on anything else but that's
what i decided to do and now
people are lying and spreading rumors
and lies and attacking my mom my only
child
going to my grandmother's house her only
grandchild
and
and my kid it's just um
i felt
so bad i i just felt bad for my mom and
i felt
horrible for picking this job and being
the one that always wants to help and
always there
never missing out one election i just
felt like it was it was my fault for
putting my family in this situation
well it wasn't your fault
your mother was kind enough to come
speak with us earlier
let's listen to her story and her words
my name is ruby freeman
i've always believed that when god says
that he'll make your name great but
this is not the way it was supposed to
be
i
could have never imagined the events
that followed the presidential election
2020.
for my entire professional life i was
lady ruby
my community in georgia
where i was born and lived my whole life
knew me as lady ruby
i built my own business
around that name la ruby's unique
treasures
a pop-up shop catering to ladies with
unique fashions
i wore a shirt that proudly proclaimed
that i was
and i am
lady ruby
actually i had that shirt on
i had that shirt in every color
i wore that shirt on election day 2020
i haven't worn it since
and i'll never wear it again
now i won't even introduce my
self by my name anymore
i get nervous when i bump into someone
i know in the grocery store who says my
name
i'm worried about
who's listening
i get nervous when i have to give my
name for food orders i'm always
concerned of who's around me
i've lost my name and i've lost my
reputation
i've lost my sense of security
all because a group of people starting
with number 45
and his ally rudy giuliani
decided to scapegoat me and my daughter
shea
to push their own lies about how the
presidential election was stolen
ms moss how is this experience of being
targeted by the former president and his
allies affected your
life just turned my life
upside down um
i no longer give out my business card
i don't transfer calls
i um
i don't want anyone knowing my name
i don't want to go anywhere with my mom
because she might yell my name out over
the grocery aisle or something
i don't go to the grocery store at all
i haven't been
anywhere um
at all
i've gained about 60 pounds i just
don't do nothing anymore i don't want to
go anywhere i second guess
everything that i do
it's affecting my life in a in a major
way
in every way
all because of lies
me doing my job same thing i've been
doing forever
your mother also told us that committee
about how she had to leave her own home
for her safety and go into hiding
after the fbi told her that it would not
be safe for her there before january 6th
and until the inauguration let's listen
to a clip of her story in her own words
around the week of
january 6
the fbi
informed me that i needed to leave my
home for safety
um
and i left my home for safety around
that time
understood how long did you stay out did
you you know remain outside of your home
for your own safety
i stayed away from my home for
approximately two months
it was horrible i felt homeless i felt
you know
i can't believe i can't believe this
person has caused this much damage to me
and my family
to have to leave my home
that i've lived there for 21 years
and you know i'm having to have my
neighbors watch out for me
you know um
and i have to go and stay with somebody
it was hard it was horrible
and that um your conversation with the
fbi about needing to leave your home for
your own safety or perhaps recommending
it um
if you remember was there a specific
threat that prompted that or was it the
accumulation of
threats that you had received
what prompted it was um
was getting ready to
january 6
was about to come
and they did not want me to be at home
because of all the threats and
everything that i had gotten they didn't
want
me to be there in fear of you know the
people were coming to my home and
i had a lot of that
so they didn't want me to be there just
in case something happened i asked how
long am i going to have to be at home
they said at least until the
inauguration
ms moss i understand that people once
showed up at your grandmother's house
tell us about that experience
i received a call from my grandmother
this
woman is my everything i've never even
heard her or seen her cry
ever in my life and um
she called me
screaming at the top of her lungs like
shay shea oh my gosh shade just
freaking me out
saying that um
there were people at her home
and they um you know they knocked on the
door and of course she opened it seeing
who was there who it was and they just
started
pushing their way through claiming that
they were coming in
to make a citizen's arrest
they needed to find me and my mom they
knew we were there
um
and
she was just
screaming and didn't know what to do and
i wasn't
there so you know
i just felt so helpless and so horrible
for her
and she um
[Music]
was just screaming i told her to close
the door don't open the door for anyone
and um
you know she's a 70 something i won't
say a year old woman and she
she doesn't like
having restrictions she wants to answer
the door she likes to get her steps in
walking around the neighborhood and
i had to tell her like you can't do that
you have to be safe um
you know she would tell me that
at night
um people would just continuously send
pizzas over and over to her home um you
know and they was expecting her to pay
for these large amounts of pizzas and
and
she went through a lot that she didn't
have to
and once again it made me just
feel so horrible
in addition to the personal impact this
experience has had on you and your
family
one of the things that i find most
disturbing
is how these lies discourage long-time
election workers from continuing to do
this important work
tell us if you would of the other
election workers shown in that state
farm arena video and their supervisors
how many are still election workers in
fulton county
um
there is no permanent election worker or
supervisor
in that video that's still there
and did you end up leaving you're
leaving your position as well
yes i i left
mr i want to thank you for coming to
speak with us
and thank you for your service
to our democracy
what we have just played is a truly
horrible and appalling sample
but just a sample of the things that
were said about you and your mother
following the election i want to say how
very
sorry i think we all are for what you've
gone through
and tragically you're not alone
other election workers around the
country have also been the subject of
lies and threats
no election workers should be subject to
such heinous treatment just for doing
their job
your permission i would like to give
your mother the last word
yes
we're just going to play the tape
there is nowhere i feel safe
nowhere
do you know how it feels to have
the president of the united states to
target you
the president of the united states is
supposed to represent every american
not to target one
but he targeted me
lady rooney
a small business owner a mother a proud
american citizen
who stand up
to help fulton county run an election in
the middle of the pandemic
thank you miss moss
thank you miss freeman or as
america now knows her lady ruby
for your service to fulton county
georgia our country and our democracy
mr chairman i yield back
thank you mr
chef
miss moss
yes sir i want to thank you for sharing
with us
the very troubling story of what you and
your mother experienced
the harassment of election workers like
you simply for doing your duty as public
servants
poses a threat to our democratic process
your testimony is an important
contribution to the work of our
committee
and serves as a reminder to all of us
that the safety of local election
officials is vital to ensuring that our
elections
are always
free and fair
i want to thank
our witness for joining us today
the members of the select committee they
have additional questions for today's
witness
and we ask
that you respond expeditiously in
writing to those questions
without objection members will be
permitted 10 business days to submit
statements for the record including
opening remarks and additional questions
for the witness
without objection the chair recognizes
the gentleman from california must shift
for a closing statement
more than 200 years our democracy has
been distinguished by the peaceful
transfer of power
when an american raises their right hand
and takes the presidential oath of
office
they are transformed from an ordinary
citizen
into the most powerful person in the
world
the president
this is an awesome pirate power to
acquire
it is even more awesome when is handed
on peacefully
when george washington relinquished the
office of the presidency it set a
precedent that served as a beacon
for other nations struggling against
tyranny
when ronald reagan described it as a
kind of miracle in the eyes of the world
he was exactly right
other countries use violence to seize
and hold power
but not in the united states
not in america
when donald trump used the power of the
presidency to try to stay in office
after losing the election to joe biden
he broke that sacred and centuries-old
covenant
whether his actions were criminal will
ultimately be for others to decide
but what he did was without a doubt
unconstitutional
it was
unpatriotic and it was fundamentally
un-american
and when he used the power of his
presidency to put the enormous pressure
on state local and local elections
officials and his own vice president
it became downright dangerous
on january 6th that pressure became
deadly
ruby freeman said the president is
supposed to protect every american not
target them
and she is right
if the most powerful person in the world
can bring the full weight of the
presidency down on an ordinary citizen
who is merely doing her job
with a lie as big and heavy as a
mountain
who among us is safe
none of us is
none of us
in city councils and town councils
on school boards and election boards
from the congress to the courts
dedicated public servants are leaving
their posts because of death threats
to them
and to their families
this is not who we are
it must not become who we are
our democracy held because courageous
people like those you heard from today
put their oath
to the constitution
above their loyalty to one man or to one
party
the system held but barely
and the question remains will it hold
again
if we are able to communicate anything
during these hearings i hope it is this
we have been blessed beyond measured to
live in the world's greatest
democracy
that is a legacy to be proud of and to
cherish
but it is not one to be taken for
granted
that we have lived in a democracy for
more than 200 years does not mean we
shall do so tomorrow
we must reject violence we must embrace
our constitution with the reverence it
deserves
take our oath of office and duties as
citizens seriously
informed by the knowledge of right and
wrong and armed
with no more than the power of our ideas
and the truth
carry on this venerable experiment
in self-governance
thank you mr chairman and i yield back
without objection the chair recognized
the gentlewoman from wyoming ms cheney
for a closing statement thank you very
much mr chairman
lady ruby and shea thank you for your
courage thank you for your strength
thank you for for being here today it it
means so much for everyone to hear your
story so thank you for that
um we have had tremendous uh testimony
today we've been reminded that we're a
nation of laws and we've been reminded
by you
and by speaker bowers and secretary of
state rather burger mr sterling that our
institutions don't defend themselves
individuals do that
and we reminded that
it takes public servants it takes people
who've made a commitment to our system
to defend our system
we also have been reminded what it means
to take an oath under god to the
constitution
what it means to defend the constitution
and we were reminded by speaker bowers
that our constitution is indeed a
divinely inspired document
uh and so it's been an honor to spend
time with you and with our previous
witnesses here today
to date more than 30 witnesses called
before this committee
have not done what you've done but have
invoked their fifth amendment rights
against self-incrimination
roger stone took the fifth general
michael flynn took the fifth john
eastman took the fifth
others like steve bannon and peter
navarro simply refused to comply with
lawful subpoenas and they have been
indicted
mark meadows has hidden behind president
trump's claims of executive privilege
and immunity from subpoenas
we're engaged now in litigation with mr
meadows
the american people in our hearings have
heard from bill barr jeff rosen richard
donahue and many others who stood up and
did what is right
and they will hear more of that
testimony soon
but the american people have not yet
heard from mr trump's former white house
counsel pat sipoloni
our committee is certain that donald
trump does not want mr sipoloni to
testify here
indeed our evidence shows that mr
sipoloni and his office tried to do what
was right they tried to stop a number of
president trump's plans for january 6th
today and in our coming hearings you
will hear testimony from other trump
white house staff
explaining what mr sipoloni said and did
including on january 6th
but we think the american people deserve
to hear from mr sipoloni personally
he should appear before this committee
and we are working to secure his
testimony thank you mr chairman i yield
back
people answer the call to public service
in such different ways
some run for office
some volunteer to make sure that
neighbors can get
to their voting locations
some work at polling sites to help
election day go smoothly
some look into problems to guarantee our
elections are secure and
just to name a few
as i mentioned at the start of this
hearing
when we talk about our democratic
institutions
we're talking about
these individuals and many others who do
these jobs across the country
they represent the backbone of our
democracy
at its most important moments
when the citizens cast their votes
and when those votes are counted
we've heard the stories of their courage
they've earned the thanks of a grateful
nation
but for donald trump
these witnesses and others like them
were another roadblock to his attempt
to cling to power
on thursday we'll hear about another
part of that scheme
his attempt to corrupt the country's top
law enforcement body
the justice department
to support his attempt to overturn the
election
just as we heard today
that donald trump was deeply involved in
the scheme to pressure state officials
to overturn the election results
we're here we will hear on thursday that
donald trump
was also the driving force behind the
effort to corrupt the justice department
listen to this clip
from the former acting attorney general
richard donahue
the president says suppose i do this so
pros i replace
jeff rosen with him jeff clark
what do you do and i said sir i would
resign immediately there is no way i'm
serving one minute under
this guy jeff clark
you'll hear from mr donohue in person on
thursday
as my colleague mr kenzinger presents
details about this plan
the chair requests those in the hearing
room remain seated
until the capitol police have escorted
members
from the room
without objection the committee stands
are joined
thank you
please
uh
hmm
thank you
okay
from
uh
i think
where would you want to go
in the background
foreign
[Music]
oh
all right
[Music]
yes
yes
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
she very clearly
yeah she said she actually said uh she
actually said i'm sorry
come explain to us
thank you
um
okay
[Music]